hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
bekommen zu einem wieder mal wer
experimentellen selbstexperiment und
zwar möchte ich mir nach fünf jahren
endlich mal die haare entfernen jeske
rolf du hast richtig gehört die haare
entfernen und jetzt fragst du dich aber
hält du hast doch braune haare was gibt
es da so zu entfernen in diesen jahren
steckt sowie farbe dass ich kaum noch
aufzählen kann was da drin steckt im
letzten jahr alleine hatte ich rosa blau
schwarze und blonde haare
ich weiß nicht warum ich mir so oft die
haare färben vielleicht das ist so eine
art selbstfindung ich habe mich
definitiv noch nicht selbst gefunden
wenn ihr euch schon selbst gefunden
haben für euch aber ich bin doch nicht
da und somit dem frühling möchte man
sich auch ein bisschen selbst reinigen
mit hahn werbungs mittel ja mein ich hab
das schon so oft bei dm gesehen und
dachte mir immer so was seine haare
entfernen
noch nie hat jemand darüber gesprochen
seine haare zu entfernen also ich bin
noch nie über ein video auf youtube
gestoßen wie jemand gesagt hat hey ich
entferne meine haare
es geht halt immer nur zu färben und ich
habe die hoffnung weil meine haare jahr
ist wie bei einer baumrinde habe ich so
verschiedene stufen hier ist immer so
natur dann kommt immer so ein schwarzer
streifen weil ich sie mir regelmäßig
dunkel nachfrage lasse aber nur dieser
teil hält diese farbe fest der
restschuld das immer wieder ab und
hinterlässt halt so zum grau braun rot
ein bisschen rang schlich was hier unten
halt stattfindet und meine hoffnung ist
jetzt dass wenn ich das alles raus
ziehen dass die heizung balasz rauskommt
so wird nicht passieren oder so umdrehen
könnte ja sein
ab hier uns hier dann so heller wird ist
halt ein schöner übergangs seid ihr
bereit für diese reise und ich muss mein
fenster zumachen weil es draußen einfach
zu laut ist das problem ist nur dass
dieses zeug dass es stinkt wie verfaulte
eier ich bin ein bisschen kann das
könnte mir heute vom vorteil sein aber
trotzdem ich habe echt angst ok juli
vannes beck ich hoffe ihr habt genauso
wie ich und scheidet nicht nach vorne
und gleich das ergebnis zu sehen denn
die reise ist das ziel der weg ist das
ziel
ok wenn wir es jetzt nicht aushalte dann
schaltet kurz nach vorne schaut euch an
wie das ergebnis aussieht aber dann
kommt auch wieder zurück und das was ich
sage ist absolut spannend großartig und
ein spaß für die ganze familie so was
haben wir hier rimowa bm activator und
buffer nachdem durchführung des
haarsträhnen test hätten die erstmals
ihre kopfhaut auch wer macht das ich hab
noch nie mann kennengelernt der seiner
kopfhaut feuer mit der farbe testet
schützen sie ihre kleiderwahl kala b 4
flecken auf kleidern und möbeln
verursachen kann der weg
wie funktioniert kala b 404 kehrt den
oben beschriebenen prozess um werden die
komponente a und b gemischt und auf die
hand geben so sind sie in der lage eine
große moleküle der künstlichen half aus
ihre normalgröße zu verkleinern
[Musik]
der wichtigste schritt im prozess von
kala b 4 ist die schutz behandlung und
das spülen haben kann man den applikator
von komponente b entfernen activator
aktivieren ich möchte die geheime zutat
für die power girls
die chemikalie liegt ok welches die
kunden schütteln 1234 können flex 7 8 9
10 11 24 27 59 60 und jetzt jedoch nokia
brauche ich es so anders wird als gut
alles gut
freilich rum
ich glaube ich mich doch nicht mehr
machen oh gott es stinkt widerlich okay
du bist ein ninja konzentriere dich
nicht auf den geruch 40 400
hier wird ist geil com farbe entweiche
denkt an was anderes an blumen an schöne
dinge die dir gefallen stehen kennen die
eier nur daran denke ich ich muss aber
an blumen denken oder die schweißfüße
seiner mutter ich hatte mein leben wird
aber noch eine zweite packen nicht sehr
langsam das glaub ich nicht reichen wird
beim einen furchtbaren dicken haaren
dann gibt aber für hygiene und jeder
jetzt mit den handballen und lud mich
scheiße volumen wenn ich vielleicht tot
umfalle leute das nicht liegen
ehrlich sagen aber die konsistenz von
diesem zeug und meine haare glänzend und
geschmeidig nicht gleich noch eine
zweite packung ein okay packen wir uns
60 minuten soll das ist ein wirklich
geil wenn jede menge würde glatt zu
stehen oder so abrasierte haare beim
melina so viel und jetzt kommt der
schönste bart beim haare werden das
aufräumen was geht alles klar bei dir
wie später haben sie das haar und lassen
die spannung ich muss jetzt 20 minuten
lang ausspülen
[Musik]
hier sind soll hält trotzdem bleibe ich
hier im untersee behandlung
meine sünden werden reingewaschen
[Musik]
handbook mehr hier das ist aus dem
urlaub also doch die sind sowieso ein
heller geworden
crazy warum habe ich so rotes haar
meinem aussehen der so war ich weiß
nicht was ich davon halten soll
die wirte jetzt einmal für mich so
anders
red ich würde ja auch noch dunkler weil
ich das passt nicht so gut ausgespielt
hatte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe meine haare entfärbt in der c
wir brauchen glaube ich nicht darüber
reden bis dieser haarfarbe nichts ist
wie bist du nicht mal wie man diese habe
beschreiben sollte ich meine es ist
keine katastrophe
das nicht aber es ist halt auch nicht
gerne erreicht man mit dem juli leiten
wir übertreiben who was sagt ihr
hier wird zwei möglichkeiten entweder
ich werde jetzt etwas dunkleres wieder
drüber was die stunden arbeit einfach
zerstören würde
oder ich hole mir nochmal entfernungs
zeug oder nochmal was drauf zehn
bisschen aus wie eine verrückte auf
hätte also so fühle ich mich ihr wisst
ihr was ich lasse es ist einfach für ein
paar tage ich habe sie heute schon
gequält
meine haare und ja vielleicht gibt es
ein teil 2 wer weiß
diesen märkten ich bringe meine kinder
zum sport game ja ja ich hab euch das
video gefallen auch wenn es ein bisschen
sinnlos ist muss auch mal sein
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
folgt mir auf instagram tik tok twitter
tweets leute es gibt so viele
möglichkeiten mit zu zeugen
bis dahin tschüss eure meinung ist dass
die stadt